what is causality and what is the
difference between causality and
correlation causality is the
relationship between a cause and an
effect
in a causal relationship we have a cause
and a resultant effect an example coffee
contains caffeine a stimulating
substance when you drink coffee the
caffeine enters the body affects the
central nervous system and leads to
increased alertedness drinking coffee is
the cause of the feeling of alertedness
that comes afterwards without drinking
coffee the effect I.E the feeling of
alertedness would not occur but
causality is not always so easy to
determine clear requirements must be met
in order to speak of a cause and
relationship but more about that later
so what is the difference between
correlation and causality a correlation
tells us that there is a relationship
between two variables example there is a
positive correlation between ice cream
sales and a number of sunburns however
an existing in correlation cannot tell
us which variable influences which or
whether a third variable is responsible
for the correlation in our example both
variables are influenced by a common
cause namely sunny weather on sunny days
people buy more ice cream and spend more
time Outdoors this can lead to an
increased risk of sunburns causality
means that there is a clear cause effect
relationship between two variables
causality exists when you can say with
certainty which variable influences
which however a common mistake in the
interpretation of Statistics is that a
correlation is immediately assumed to be
a causal relationship here is an example
the American statistician Daryl Huff
found a negative correlation between the
number of head lines and the body
temperature future of the inhabitants of
an island a negative correlation means
that people with many head lice
generally have a lower body temperature
and people with few head lice generally
have a higher body temperature the
Islanders concluded that head lice were
good for health because the reduced
fever so their assumption was that
headlights have an effect on the
temperature of the body in reality the
correct conclusion is the other way
around in an experiment it was possible
to prove that high fever drives away the
lies so the high body temperature is the
cause not the effect what are the
conditions for talking about causality
there are two conditions for causality
number one there is a significant
correlation between the variables this
is easy to check we simply check whether
the correlation coefficient is
significantly different from zero row
number two the second condition can be
met in three ways first chronological
sequence there is a chronological
sequence and the results of one variable
occurred before the results of the other
variable second experiment a controlled
experiment was conducted in which the
two variables can be specifically
influenced and number three Theory there
is a well-founded and plausible theory
in which direction the causal
relationship goes if there is only a
significant correlation but none of the
other three conditions are met we can
only speak of correlation never of
causality thanks for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the video